foreign
Scotland's first Minister Nicholas
surgeons just announced her resignation
after more than eight years sturgeon's
been in the position since 2014.
this decision is not a reaction to
short-term pressures
of course there are difficult issues
confronting the government just now
but when is that ever not the case
I have spent almost three decades in
Frontline politics a decade and a half
on the top or second top rung of
government
when it comes to navigating choppy
Waters resolving seemingly intractable
issues or soldiering on when walking
away would be the simpler option I have
plenty of experience to draw on
so if this was just a question of my
ability or my resilience to get through
the latest period of pressure I wouldn't
be standing here today but it's not
this decision comes from a deeper and
longer term assessment
we're going to get more on this with
Rory challenge in London Rory I
understand Nicholas sturgeon in fact is
still carrying on making that statement
at the moment this in many ways is an
upheaval in Scottish politics given the
length of time she's been in office what
has she been saying in this statement
yeah you're certainly right about an
upheaval I mean we we're used to at the
moment aren't we upheaval uh in
Westminster politics with prime
ministers coming and going uh with a
dizzying speed but north of the Border
things have been much much more stable
uh for many many years Nicholas sturgeon
the longest uh serving uh first minister
of Scotland she said that stepping down
was a very hard decision to make but
that as a leader you have to kind of
intuitively know when the time is right
to make way for someone else and she
thinks that that time is now she said
that there were a couple of questions
that she has been asking herself
recently the first of those is is
carrying on right for me and the second
of them is is me carrying on right for
the country and right for the party and
she said recently she wasn't so
convinced that the answer to both of
those questions uh was yes she talked
about the personal toll that's the the
pressures of the job have been taking on
her she said she wasn't expecting
violins for this but there's only so
long she said that you can give
everything to a job it takes its toll
and more so recently she was suggesting
the pandemic she said was particularly
tough and also she was hinting at Pat 's
decisions that she's taken choices that
she's made positions that she holds that
aren't necessarily shared by the rest of
her party and that in stepping down she
would free the party to choose a new
leader and go forward now as for the
timeline of that there will of course be
a process which is going to start now to
choose the next leader of the Scottish
international party and that Nicholas
sturgeon will be staying on in her role
until that process is completed we don't
know how long that's going to take but
that's the process that has to be done
Rory thank you very much indeed Rory
Chan's bringing us up to date there
thank you